and let me tell you this even if we was  ready for the green agenda I raised my  hand right now but we're not ready right  now so don't let them fool you like this  is a new agenda this is not a new agenda  we're not prepared we're not ready right  now what we need to do is keep damn  those gas gunsling cars so we got good  emission out of those cars we're doing  the best thing that we can but we need  help we need help and those other people  not helping us China's not helping us in  here not helping us but yeah we're gonna  do it all because they spending your  money  doesn't make any sense I know that most  of those words are English but it  doesn't make any sense